>> Kevin: WOLVES HAVE A TIMEOUT
AND THEY GIVE IT TO EDWARDS.
THEY HOLD THE BALL, THE CLOCK IS
TICKING, A FOUL COMMITTED BY
BATUM.
6.4.
BEASLEY WILL BE AT THE LINE.
IT IS A PLAYOFF ATMOSPHERE IN
THIS PLAY-IN GAME.
AND RUSSELL WAS AT HIS BEST.
HE HAD ONE POINT, RUSSELL HAD
ONE POINT IN THE FIRST QUARTER.
HE HAD 28 OVER THE NEXT THREE
QUARTERS OF THE GAME.
>> Reggie: WELL, WE TALKED ABOUT
HIM BEING THE X-FACTOR, RIGHT?
IF THERE WAS EVER A GAME HE
NEEDED TO STEP UP WITH
KARL-ANTHONY TOWNS GOING 11
POINTS AND FOULING OUT, IT WAS
TONIGHT.
>> Kevin: BEASLEY WITH THE
STRIKE.
BY BEVERLEY AND THAT'S ALL SHE
WROTE!
THE TIMBERWOLVES ARE GOING TO
THE PLAYOFFS!
>> Kevin: THE TIMBERWOLVES IN
THE PLAYOFFS FOR THE SECOND TIME
SINCE 2004.
THEY WON IN 2018 WITH JIMMY
BUTLER AND THEY'RE GOING IN 2022
LED BY PATRICK BEVERLEY WHO HAS
BECOME, IN HIS FIRST YEAR, THE
MOST IMPACTFUL PLAYER AND
CLEARLY THE HEART AND SOUL AS HE
HUGS HIS FORMER TEAMMATES WHERE
HE PLAYED POR FOUR YEARS.
AND, REGGIE, IT'S CLEAR TO SAY
THAT IT'S PERSONAL FOR HIM
TONIGHT.
>> Reggie: IT'S NICE TO SEE THAT
HE STILL HAS RESPECT IN THE
LOCKER ROOM FOR THE CLIPPERS,
BUT THIS HAS TO FEEL GOOD FOR
HIM.
>> Kevin: THE CLIPPERS WILL HAVE
ANOTHER CHANCE FRIDAY AT HOME
AGAINST THE WINNER OF NEW
ORLEANS AND SAN ANTONIO.
WE'LL FINISH UP THAT IN A
SECOND.
OUT TO THE FLOOR AND ALLY
REPORTS.
>> Reporter: AS YOU WATCH YOUR
TEAM CELEBRATE IN FRONT OF THIS
HOME CROWD.
YOU HIT THE BUCKET THAT GAVE THE
TEAM THE BIGGEST LEAD IN THE
GAME.
HE SAID IT'S OKAY, WE GOT THIS.
WHAT GAVE YOU THE CONFIDENCE TO
BE SO CALM OUT THERE?
>> WE HAVE A SPECIAL GROUP.
TODAY WE LOCKED IN TO THE
DETAILS OF WHAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE TO BEAT THAT TEAM, WHICH
THEY'RE A GOOD TEAM WELL
COACHED.
THIS IS OUR FIRST TB GAME ALL
YEAR.
OUR FANS ARE AMAZING.
THIS IS SPECIAL.
>> Reporter: IT IS TRULY AMAZING
AND WE'LL SHOW THAT.
YOU DID THAT WITH KARL-ANTHONY
TOWNS ON THE COURT AND TONIGHT
YOU HAD TO DO IT WITHOUT HIM.
AFTER THE GAME WHEN YOU HUGGED
HIM, WHAT DID YOU TELL HIM, AND
HOW DID YOU GUYS OVERCOME IT?
>> THAT'S OUR STAR.
HE'S BEEN HOLDING IT DOWN FOR US
ALL SEASON.
TONIGHT THEIR GAME PLAN WAS TO
TAKE OUT THE GAME, AND I
WOULDN'T TAKE ANY OTHER GROUP
OTHER THAN OURS.
WE'VE GOT 12 OR 15 GUYS THAT CAN
SHOW UP AND DOMINATE, SO WE'RE
COMMITTED TO THAT.
>> Reporter: ARE YOU ABLE TO PUT
INTO WORDS WHAT IT MEANS FOR
THIS TEAM?
>> WE'RE SUPPOSED TO TAKE CARE
OF BUSINESS TONIGHT.
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO TAKE CARE OF
BUSINESS IN MEMPHIS.
>> Reporter: CONGRATS ON THE
WIN.
ENJOY IT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Kevin: HE WAS THE SECOND
OVERALL PICK AND SELECTED BY THE
LAKERS, THEN TRADED TO BROOKLYN,
THEN GOLDEN STATE AND COMING TO
MINNESOTA.
AND IN THIS SEASON AND IN A
PREVIOUS GAME FOR HIM, HE HAS
ANSWERED THE BELL ALONG WITH THE
REST OF THE TEAM.
>> Reggie: THIS IS WHY TEAM
SPORTS ARE BEAUTIFUL.
WHEN YOU'VE GOT A BAND OF
BROTHERS, AND HE HIGHLIGHTED OUR
BEST PLAYER, OUR CAPTAIN, OUR
ALL-STAR STRUGGLED TONIGHT, AND
A BAND OF BROTHERS CAME TOGETHER
AND FOUND A WAY TO WIN AND MOVE
ON AND OFFICIALLY END THE
PLAYOFFS TO GO AGAINST THE
NUMBER 2 SEEDED MEMPHIS
GRIZZLIES.
>> Kevin: YOU DON'T THINK THIS
GAME MEANT SOMETHING TO FORMER
CLIPPER PATRICK BEVERLEY AT 32
YEARS OF AGE?
THE TEARS OF JOY AND THE EMOTION
POURING OUT.
HE KNEW WHE